les serres du park à longueuil
madame la mairesse bonjour c'est réglé
vous allez devoir effectivement les
abattent en août en asie où j'avais un
rapport vous a été déposé c'est un
dossier réglé comment vous comprenez la
solution qu'est ce qui va arriver mais
d'abord important de remettre et
distribution dans le processus qu'on va
dévoiler demain matin ce qui va être
rendu public sur le site web la ville de
longueuil à se taire c'est leur rapport
de la table de concertation qui a été
mise en place et quelques mois est une
table qui réunit des citoyens des
experts des scientifiques qui a consulté
une revue de littérature est un sportif
très imposante qui est également entendu
différents groupes toutes les
possibilités ont été analysés pour
assurer l'équilibré écologique du parc
michel chartrand que c'est vraiment ce
qui est offert imessage la table de
recommandation la table de concertation
le pardon donc ce sont des
recommandations qui vont nous permettre
d'agir sur les trois facteurs qui
expliquent pourquoi les milieux naturels
se sont dégradées au point qu'ils
parviennent plus à se régénérer ce n'est
pas reparti seul enjeu actuellement donc
les effets dévastateurs de l'agrile du
frêne il ya la propagation des espèces
exotiques envahissantes notamment raison
les changements climatiques et
finalement meilleure alimentation des
cerfs de virginie qui sont actuellement
minimalement cinq fois plus nombreux que
ce que peut soutenir le parti michel
chartrand donc c'est clair qu'ils les
solutions de réduction du cheptel qui
vont devoir être entreprises il y en os
il y en a 70 à peu près des salles
d'accueil en injuste l'homme les poppers
et pop heureux il y en a peu apprécié en
dise le parc peut en fait revivre une
dizaine donc qui arrive qu 60e vous
allez devoir les abattre il va devoir y
avoir des solutions à court et à long
terme parce qu'on sait que même sans
crédit le cheptel mais dans les
prochaines années ça risque d'augmenter
donc va falloir qu'ils aient vraiment
des mesures qui soient mises en place
notamment et on va analyser la question
de la stérilisation mais pour ce qui est
de maintenant effectivement on va devoir
prendre des actions pour réduire
immédiatement en egypte est donc la
capture l'euthanasie par la suite le
d'offrir la viande à des organismes
communautaires toit permet de valeur
les arts de cette façon ce qui devait
être fait
vous êtes tout ça pour chats ce qui
devait être fait il ya eu des gens qui
s'y sont opposés et on revient à ce
qu'on avait décidé flammes en fait ils
processus qui est important moi je pense
que c'est intéressant qu'on ait pu
entendre faire en groupe constats sont
vraiment que toutes les solutions ont
été analysés par que l'année dernière ça
n'avait pas été communiqué de cette
façon là y'avait pas nécessairement le
travail en amont qui avait été fait donc
lors cet astérix est ce que le
déplacement était possible
malheureusement non pour les effets de
stress pour les effets également de la
maladie de lyme qui est très présente
ici dans la région qu'on ne vais pas
exporté dans d'autres régions puis en
fait l'heure pourquoi l'urgence est
encore plus grande
ces convois qui restèrent actuellement
sont dans des conditions de vie vraiment
déplorable ils sont sous alimentés puis
le nombre vraiment explosé même dans la
dernière année parce que le stoppeur
exponentielle en fait à chaque année
avec à la période de gestation la misa
bug qui a eu lieu au printemps donc on
serait même plutôt près d'une centaine
de serre à l'heure actuelle donc d'où
l'importance d'engager rapidement nous
on va avoir besoin de la collaboration
d'uniterre d'afone et des parcs le dans
le dossier parce qu'on va avoir besoin
des permis parce que plus on attend
malheureusement plus il va y avoir un
cheptel important idéalement vous
commenceriez qu'un usager légère lancé à
l'automne au printemps ça va devoir être
analysés notamment avec le comité
d'éthique de l'université de montréal
non ferai rien sans avoir leur avaient à
leur approbation stream important de
bien faire les choses on sait que c'est
un dossier sensible on veut qu'il y ait
le moins de souffrance animale
impossible pour ces également que toutes
les solutions ont été étudiées on veut
on va prendre le temps de bien faire les
choses avec des vétérinaires également
des scientifiques et qu'ils vont nous
accompagner dans le processus d une fois
qu'on a obtenu une certitude bons soins
la part du comité d'éthique on va
pouvoir avoir à l'hyper ni des mets
festifs ça va nous permettre de procéder
mais évidemment on souhaiterait que ce
soit le plus rapidement possible parce
que son rapport d'une année mais
malheureusement les cheptels va être
encore plus grand c'est certain que ça
va devoir être une opération la plus
importante mais je répète si on avait
procédé
alors qu'on voulait le faire le problème
aurait été réglé c'est comme si on leur
a poussé le problème en fait c'est qu'il
n'y a pas seulement l'enjeu dessert je
pense que c'est que la table voulu
mettre de l'avant également ya plusieurs
jours en jeu qui a fait l'état des
milieux naturels et sinon par michel
chartrand laisse r c'est effectivement
la première voie de passage donc il faut
régler pour s'attaquer aux autres
problèmes sont construits pas capable de
le faire mais néanmoins nous on
considère qu'il est le travail qui a été
réalisé par la table de concertation
elle a été important je pense qu'il va
me faire des petits à travers le québec
comment on gère une station comme
système d'éducation ce que tu as peut
être un modèle innovateur qui veulent
espérer d'autres villes de la région qui
sont aux prises avec avec les moyens de
problèmes parce que l'enjeu est le même
dans tous les grands parcs de la
montérégie finalement donc ya une
surpopulation de serre dues aux
changements climatiques mais aussi au
changement de nos habitudes long les
gens n'auraient sein de faire plus liste
plus les soirs au cours des dernières
années donc ce que l'ong est en train de
faire ici ces précurseurs pour
l'ensemble de la région qui on sait que
d'autres villes qui attendent le rapport
et cette fois ci la table de
concertation analyser toutes les avenues
possibles on le sait qu'il y avait eu un
travail qui avait été fait en amont
cours des dernières années par contre le
cette fois ci tout est bien documenté et
ça sera disponible pour le public
m'avait bouclier vous faites quoi madame
amara sy ça y est les gens
qui aiment les animaux puis avec qui des
bons sentiments viens de vous dire vous
pouvez pas tuer les chevreuils pas de
quoi mais nous on aime les animaux mais
justement il n'ya pas seulement lester
place sur place on sert ça affecte
également les autres espèces et
l'écosystème en fait j'espère qu'une
chaire chartrand donc nous nous posons
les très clair depuis le départ on veut
se fier sur la science un processus qui
a été fait de façon indépendante qui
sera transparent également partir toutes
les recommandations seront disponibles
au public donc nous on veut suivre les
recommandations sont veut s'assurer que
le parc demeure accessible pour les
citoyens et les citoyens non seulement
longuet mais de toute la région parce
qu'ils soient parquet général il ya des
décisions qui s'imposent pour des
sanctions facile on va devoir maintenir
le cap et il ya personne qui fait ici de
gaieté cas s'est fait parce que c'est la
seule avenue possible c'est la seule
option viable à long terme et à court
terme dans ce que si je peux vous dire
en tant que conseiller municipal du
district ici l'opinion populaire
énormément évolué donc au courant de la
dernière opération il y avait une large
position finalement façon fort parce que
l'information n'avait pas été 30 mises
ensemble la population et je peux
confirmer qu'au cours des derniers mois
c'est l'inversé qui est en finale très
bien merci beaucoup pour ces précisions
merci